welcome in the sting and why don't we
start the episode off with a new segment
Tellem Brendon little rip my drip you've
seen the Oscars do it you've seen us do
it on E well me not the oh you've seen
us do it though time to rip that drip
yeah who lifts we bro easy lift weights
you steroid you idiot who doesn't know
we're you doing five milligrams let's
get you on this on this pedal stool up
there let me see what he's rocking with
here this the outfit of the day it is a
lovely Tuesday and feel decide to wear
this huh that's yeah that's that's the
style for a Tuesday ah excuse me sir
dude you look like you carpool with your
mom in a [ __ ] subaru forrester every
day you look like you have churros in
your pocket what are you wearing brother
what the [ __ ] what are those pants dude
those are outta my hands those are what
outdoors as a proud ores outdoors why
they pulled up like that huh that's how
they do you look like [ __ ] Baloo from
tailspin with those [ __ ] pants you
know you look like you just got fired
from Red Robin let's bring it up dude
let's bring up Brin and Sam here okay if
you can bring up Barry shop you look
like NASCAR arouses you yeah quit
ripping my drift bro I want to rip his
drip let's throw up on the brain you
bring up that stylish [ __ ] oh my
god bro what's up bro you look like the
strongest female figure skater I've ever
seen hey awesome peacoats huh on them
Pecos you look like obviously you sell a
cologne at a gas station okay dude you
look like a dude that's been held back
in every grade you're 32 years old in
high school and you're still asking
[ __ ] sophomores for rides home though
that necklace you that thing is so fake
bro fake it I could buy your mom's
trailer with this thing like the
ballerina that's in a little girls
Reeboks dude it's your life together
[Music]